maligayang pagbabalik sa pag-unawa sa Quantum information at computation ang pangalan ko ay John Watrous at ako ang technical director para sa edukasyon
sa IBM Quantum ito ang ikasampu na aralin ng serye at ito ang unang aralin ng ikatlong unit na tungkol sa pangkalahatang
pormulasyon ng quantum information hanggang ngayon gumagamit tayo ng pinasimpleng pormulasyon ng
quantum information kung saan ang mga Quantum state ay kinakatawan ng mga complex vector na may Euclidean Norm na katumbas ng
isa sa kabilang dako sa pangkalahatang pormulasyon ng quantum information ang mga Quantum state ay kinakatawan ng
mga matrix ng isang partikular na uri na kilala bilang density matrices ang unang aralin ng unit na ito ay nakatuon sa density matrices nang partikular
at malalaman natin kung ano sila at kung paano sila gumagana habang nagpapatuloy ang aralin ang mga density matrix ay lubhang
kapaki-pakinabang at nag-aalok sila ng iba't ibang kalamangan na tatalakayin natin pinapayagan nila tayong kumatawan ng
mas malawak na klase ng mga state kaysa sa magagawa ng mga Quantum State vector kabilang ang mga state ng mga sistema na naapektuhan ng ingay halimbawa gayundin ang mga random
na pagpili ng mga quantum state titingnan din natin ang Block sphere na nagbibigay sa atin ng napakagandang
at simpleng geometric na paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol sa mga Cubit State at makikita natin kung paano ito kumokonekta sa density matrices sa isang
medyo kahanga-hangang paraan sa pamamagitan ng mga Pauli matrix sa wakas tatalakayin natin ang mga density matrix sa konteksto ng maraming
sistema at sa partikular makikita natin kung paano nila pinapayagan tayong ilarawan ang mga Quantum State ng mga sistema na tinitingnan nang nag-iisa kahit na
sila ay magkakaugnay sa ibang mga sistema at kasama rito ang posibilidad na sila ay magkasangkot sa ibang mga sistema ito ay isang mahalagang bagay na
magagawa at hindi ito madaling gawin sa loob ng pinasimpleng pormulasyon ng quantum information narito ang pangkalahatang-ideya ng
aralin magsisimula tayo sa mga pangunahing kaalaman ng density matrices kabilang ang mga kaugnay na kahulugan at ilang halimbawa at
tatalakayin din natin kung paano sila kumokonekta sa mga Quantum State vector pagkatapos ay pag-uusapan natin ang mga convex combination ng density matrices o sa
madaling salita kung ano ang nangyayari kapag kumukuha tayo ng mga weighted average ng density matrices magsisimula tayo sa isang partikular
na halimbawa ng tinatawag na completely mixed state makikita natin kung paano ang mga classical probabilistic state ay maaaring ituring bilang
mga espesyal na kaso ng density matrices at tatalakayin natin kung paano ang spectral theorem mula sa linear algebra ay gumaganap
sa kontekstong ito ang ikatlong bahagi ng aralin ay tungkol sa Block sphere na nagbibigay ng geometric na paraan ng pagtingin sa mga state ng
mga single cubit tulad ng nabanggit ko sa simula ng aralin at sa ikaapat na bahagi ng aralin ay pag-uusapan natin kung paano gumagana ang mga density matrix para sa maraming
sistema tatalakayin natin ang mga product state at mga correlated state ng iba't ibang uri kabilang ang mga entangled state gayundin
ang konsepto ng reduced state na isang density Matrix na paglalarawan ng state ng isang nakahiwalay na bahagi ng isang compound system
na maaaring kalkulahin gamit ang isang operasyon na kilala bilang partial Trace bago tayo makarating sa teknikal na nilalaman ng aralin mismo
nararapat na maglaan ng ilang sandali upang bigyang-motibasyon ang paggamit ng density matrices gamit ang pinasimpleng
pormulasyon ng quantum information na hindi gumagamit ng density matrices nagagawa nating ilarawan ang mga Quantum algorithm tulad ng
algoritmo ng pagfactor ni Shor halimbawa nang walang anumang kahirapan kaya bakit pa tayo mag-abala sa mga density matrix
o sa pangkalahatang pormulasyong ito ng quantum information sa lahat may maraming dahilan una ang mga density matrix
ay kumakatawan sa mas malawak na klase ng mga quantum state kaysa sa mga Quantum State vector kabilang ang mga Quantum state kung saan mayroon tayong kawalan ng katiyakan o
Randomness ito ay mahalaga kapag nais nating i-modelo ang mga epekto ng ingay sa mga Quantum computation halimbawa
ikalawa gamit ang mga density matrix maaari tayong maglarawan ng mga Quantum state ng mga nakahiwalay na bahagi ng mga compound system tulad
ng mga state ng mga sistema na magkasangkot sa ibang mga sistema na maaaring pansamantalang pinili nating balewalain tulad ng nabanggit ko sa simula ng
aralin hindi ito madali o natural na magagawa sa loob ng pinasimpleng pormulasyon ng quantum
information ang ikatlong dahilan ay na kapag gumagamit tayo ng mga density matrix ang classical na impormasyon ay talagang lumalabas bilang isang
espesyal na kaso kaya sa halip na magkaroon ng kung ano ang mahalagang isang analohiya sa pagitan ng mga probabilistic state at operasyon sa
isang banda at mga Quantum State vector at mga unitary na operasyon sa kabilang banda mayroon tayong Quantum at classical na impormasyon
na inilalarawan nang magkasama sa loob ng isang solong mathematical framework na halos Mahalaga sa mathematical na pag-aaral
ng quantum information kaya kung seryoso kang maunawaan ang Quantum information sa mathematical na antas lubos na
inirerekomenda na matuto ka tungkol sa mga density matrix magsimula na tayo sa kahulugan ng density
matrices para sa layunin ng kahulugan ipagpalagay na ang X ay isang sistema at ang sigma ay ang kanyang classical State set at alalahanin na
kapag ginagamit natin ang terminolohiyang iyon ang aming palagay ay ang Sigma ay finite at hindi walang laman at tulad ng dati maaari tayong pumili ng
iba't ibang pangalan kung gusto natin ang isang density Matrix na naglalarawan ng isang state ng sistema X ay isang matrix na may mga complex
na entry ng numero na ang mga hilera at haligi ay inilagay sa pagsusulatan sa classical State set nito at upang maging malinaw
ito ang parehong pagsusulatan para sa mga hilera at haligi nang sabay-sabay ibig sabihin nito ang mga density
matrix ay laging mga Square matrix at bukod sa pagiging Square mayroon din mga ilang kondisyon na kailangang
matugunan at malalaman natin ang mga ito sa ilang sandali ang mga tao ay karaniwang gumagamit ng ilang partikular na lowercase Greek na titik upang pangalanan ang mga density
matrix ang rho ay madalas na unang pagpipilian at ang iba pang karaniwang pagpipilian ay kinabibilangan ng lowercase Sigma at tau na ipinapakita sa
screen ito ay isang kombensyon lamang ngunit tulad ng dati ang mga ganitong uri ng kombensyon ay kapaki-pakinabang dahil ginagawa nitong mas
madaling makilala ang mga bagay at ngayon ay pag-usapan natin ang mga kondisyon o mga kinakailangan na dapat matugunan ng mga density matrix upang maging
mga wastong density matrix mayroon dalawa sa kanila at ang gagawin ko ay una ay ilista lamang sila
at pagkatapos ay tatalakayin ko nang mas detalyado kung ano ang ibig sabihin nila ang unang kondisyon ay ang mga density
matrix ay dapat may unit trace o sa madaling salita Trace na katumbas ng isa at ang pangalawang kondisyon ay ang
mga density matrix ay dapat na positive semi-definite at sa parehong kaso mayroon tayong maigting na simbolikong paraan ng pagpapahayag
ng dalawang kondisyong ito na lumalabas sa screen ngayon ay talakayin natin ang dalawang kondisyon nang mas detalyado
ang unang kondisyon ay tumutukoy sa trace na isang napakahalagang function na tinukoy para sa lahat ng square matrix
at ito ay simpleng kabuuan ng mga diagonal na entry at narito ang isang equation na nagpapahayag niyon
nang malinaw ngayon maraming masasabi tungkol sa trace at kung bakit ito mahalaga ngunit sa ngayon ay obserbahan lamang natin
ang isang napaka-pangunahing katangian nito na ito ay isang linear function ang iba pang mga katangian ng trace ay darating at tatalakayin natin ang mga ito habang
kailangan ngunit upang mapanatili ang ating pokus sa density matrices ay lumipat na tayo sa pangalawang kinakailangan at ang kinakailangang iyon ay ang
mga density matrix ay positive semi-definite ito rin ay isang mahalagang konsepto na lumitaw sa maraming mga setting sa
pisika kimika optimisasyon machine learning at iba pang mga paksa at maaari itong ipahayag sa ilang iba't ibang ngunit
katumbas na mga paraan ang isang paraan ng pagpapahayag nito ay ang sabihing ang isang matrix rho ay positive semi-definite kung mayroon isang matrix M
na ang rho ay katumbas ng M dagger beses M at lumalabas na hindi mahalaga kung hihilingin nating ang M mismo ay isang
square Matrix o kung aalisin natin ang paghihigpit na iyon ang isa pang paraan ng pagpapahayag kung ano ang ibig sabihin para sa isang matrix rho na maging positive
semi-definite ay ang sabihing ang rho ay Hermitian na ibig sabihin ay katumbas ito ng sarili nitong conjugate transpose at lahat ng
eigenvalue nito ay hindi negatibong tunay na mga numero sa pangkalahatan ang mga Hermitian matrix ay maaaring
magkaroon lamang ng mga tunay na eigenvalue ngunit maaaring sila ay negatibo ngunit kung isasama natin ang karagdagang paghihigpit na wala sa
mga eigenvalue ay maaaring negatibo matatamo natin ang mga positive semi-definite matrix at sa pamamagitan ng paraan kung may ibinigay sa iyo
na matrix at gusto mong malaman kung ito ay positive semi-definite maaari mong matukoy iyon gamit ang karakterisasyong ito medyo madali
na suriin kung ang isang matrix ay Hermitian o hindi iyon ay isang bagay na maaaring makita sa tingin pa lamang mas mahirap kalkulahin
ang mga eigenvalue ngunit hindi ito masyadong mahirap gawin gamit ang isang computer dahil mayroong napakaepektibong mga algoritmo para gawin ito
at ang huling karakterisasyon na babanggitin ko kahit na mayroon pa iba ay na para sa bawat column Vector s na may
bilang ng mga entry na sumasang-ayon sa bilang ng mga hilera at bilang ng mga haligi ng rho ang hindi pagkakapantay-pantay na ipinapakita sa
screen ay totoo sa mga salita ang dagger ni s beses rho beses s ay dapat na isang hindi negatibong tunay na
numero hindi halata sa pamamagitan ng paraan na ang mga karakterisasyong ito ay lahat ay katumbas ngunit sila ay at pansinin ko nang malinaw na ang
notasyon na karaniwang ginagamit natin upang ipahiwatig na ang isang matrix rho ay positive semi-definite ay mukhang ang rho ay mas malaki
kaysa o katumbas ng zero ngunit ito ay isang shorthand na notasyon lamang at hindi ito literal na nangangahulugang ang rho ay mas malaki kaysa
sa o katumbas ng zero ang rho ay isang matrix kaya hindi iyon makakatuwiran at hindi ito nangangahulugang
ang bawat entry ng rho ay mas malaki kaysa o katumbas ng zero sa partikular mayroon mga positive
semi-definite matrix na ang mga entry ay hindi lahat ay hindi negatibo at mayroon din mga matrix na ang mga entry ay lahat ay hindi
negatibo ngunit hindi sila positive semi-definite ang ideya sa likod ng notasyon ay ang mga positive semi-definite
matrix ay parang mga Matrix analogue ng mga hindi negatibong tunay na numero ngunit ito ay notasyon lamang at ang ibig sabihin nito ay
eksakto kung ano ang aming tinalakay na ngayon tingnan natin ang ilang halimbawa simula sa isang halimbawa ng isang
positive semi-definite Matrix sa katunayan medyo madaling random na lumikha ng halimbawa ng isang
positive semi-definite matrix sa pamamagitan ng simpleng pagpili ng isang matrix M nang arbitrary at pagkatapos ay pag-compute ng M dagger beses
M halimbawa narito ang isang matrix M na hindi partikular na espesyal at sa katunayan
random kong nabuo ang matrix na ito sa pamamagitan ng independiyenteng pagpili ng mga tunay at imaginary na bahagi ng mga entry upang maging mga integer sa pagitan ng negatibong 9 at positibong
9 kaya ang anumang mga pattern o istraktura dito ay purong koinsidensia sa pamamagitan ng pagmumultiply ng
conjugate transpose ng M sa M makukuha natin ang matrix na ito dito na samakatuwid ay positive
semi-definite siyempre may limitasyon kung gaano karaming kaalaman ang matatamo natin mula sa isang random na halimbawa ngunit nagpapakita ito ng ilang
mga katangian na karaniwang mayroon ang mga positive semi-definite matrix sa pangkalahatan sa partikular mapapansin mo
na ang mga diagonal na entry na nangangahulugang ang mga nasa linya mula sa itaas kaliwa hanggang sa ibaba kanan ay lahat ay hindi negatibong tunay na
numero at bukod dito ang mga off diagonal na entry ay medyo hindi masyadong malaki kumpara sa mga kaukulang diagonal
na entry na nangangahulugang ang isa sa parehong hilera at ang isa sa parehong haligi ng anumang off diagonal na entry na tinitingnan natin
mayroon pa rin higit na sasabihin dito at mahalaga na makilala na ang pagiging positive semi-definite ay isang
katangian ng isang matrix bilang kabuuan at hindi lamang isang kondisyon sa mga indibidwal na entry kaya iyan ay isang halimbawa ng isang
positive semi-definite Matrix at madali mong makabuo ng iba pang mga halimbawa sa pamamagitan ng katulad
na pamamaraan ngayon tingnan natin ang ilang halimbawa ng density matrices kung saan bukod sa kondisyong positive semidefinite mayroon din tayong ang trace ay
katumbas ng isa narito ang ilang halimbawa ng 2x2 na density matrices ang trace ay katumbas ng
isa sa lahat ng apat na kaso at makikita rin natin na ang mga ito ay mga Hermitian matrix kaya gamit ang pangalawang karakterisasyon ng
mga positive semi-definite matrix mula kanina ang natitira ay suriin na ang mga eigenvalue ay lahat ay hindi negatibo
iiiwan ko iyon para sa iyo na suriin kung nais mo para sa mga 2x2 na matrix hindi masyadong mahirap kalkulahin ang mga eigenvalue nang manu-mano
ngunit maaari ka ring humingi sa isang computer na gawin ito halimbawa maaari mong gamitin ang eigenvalues function sa linear algebra
package para sa python maaari rin tayong makakuha ng isang density matrix sa pamamagitan lamang ng pagkuha ng anumang hindi zero
positive semi-definite Matrix at paghahati nito sa kanyang trace halimbawa narito ang density Matrix na makukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng
paghahati ng halimbawa na nakita natin kaaalis lamang sa kanyang Trace ang paghahati sa pamamagitan ng trace tulad nito
ay palaging magpapanatili ng katangiang positive semi-definite at tiyak na makakakuha tayo ng matrix na may Trace na katumbas ng isa dahil sa katotohanan na
ang trace ay isang linear function iyon ay isang maliit na koleksyon ng mga halimbawa at makakakita tayo ng higit pa habang nagpapatuloy ang
aralin susunod na maglalaan tayo ng ilang sandali upang talakayin ang interpretasyon o
intuitive na kahulugan ng mga density matrix ang unang bagay na kikilalanin ay na maaaring mukhang medyo kakaiba
na kinakatawan natin ang state ng isang sistema ng isang matrix kaysa sa isang vector sa kabilang dako sa pinasimpleng
pormulasyon ng quantum information gumagamit tayo ng mga vector upang kumatawan ng mga state samantalang ang mga matrix partikular ang mga unitary matrix
ay kumakatawan ng mga aksyon o operasyon ito ay kung paano gumagana ang matematika at kahit na maaari kang
palaging mag-isip tungkol sa mga matrix bilang naglalarawan ng mga linear mapping hindi tayo karaniwang nag-uugnay ng direktang intuitive
na kahulugan sa linear mapping na nauugnay sa isang partikular na density Matrix na sinabi na ang katotohanan na ang
mga density matrix ay talagang mga matrix ay lumalabas na isang kritikal na mahalagang aspeto ng mga ito at makikita natin
iyon habang tayo ay nagpapatuloy ngunit upang maibanggit nang maikli ang isang halimbawa lamang sa ngayon ang mga eigenvalue ng isang partikular na density Matrix
ay lumalabas na napakahalagang dahil inilalarawan nila kung gaano karaming Randomness o kawalan ng katiyakan ang likas sa state
na inilalarawan ng density Matrix na iyon ang isang iba pang paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol sa mga density matrix sa isang intuitive na antas
ay nakatuon sa mga entry ng mga matrix na ito alalahanin na ang mga hilera at Haligi ng mga density matrix ay inilagay
sa pagsusulatan sa mga classical State ng anumang sistema na pinag-uusapan natin kaya para sa bawat entry mayroon tayong isa
classical State na tumutugma sa hilera ng entry na iyon at isang classical State na tumutugma sa haligi ng entry na iyon
para sa mga diagonal na entry ang dalawang classical state na iyon ay parehong state at iyan ang dahilan kung bakit ang mga diagonal na entry ay
espesyal at ang isang paraan ng pag-interpret ng mga diagonal na entry ay ang mga ito ay mga probabilidad at partikular mayroon
mga probabilidad na ang kaukulang classical state ay lilitaw kung magsasagawa tayo ng standard basis measurement
sa sistema na ang Quantum State ay inilarawan natin para sa mga off diagonal na entry sa kabilang dako mayroon tayong isang classical State na tumutugma sa hilera
ng entry na iyon at isang iba't ibang classical State na tumutugma sa haligi ng entry na iyon at sa napaka-impormal na pagsasalita
ang mga entry na ito ay naglalarawan ng antas kung saan ang dalawang classical state na ito ay nasa Quantum superposition gayundin ang
relatibong phase sa pagitan nila maaaring mas malinaw iyon habang nagpapatuloy ang aralin at tumingin tayo nang mas malapit
sa ilang partikular na halimbawa at maaaring hindi malinaw ang mga detalye sa puntong ito ngunit huwag hayaang mangamba ka rito
ito ay lubhang impormal at ito ay isang intuitive na ideya lamang na iingatan sa isip
susunod ay titingnan natin ang koneksyon sa pagitan ng mga density matrix at mga Quantum State vector na mga column
vector na may Euclidean Norm na katumbas ng isa basta alalahanin ang mathematical na kahulugan ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong isang
Quantum State Vector s na kumakatawan sa state ng ilang partikular na sistema ang density Matrix na kumakatawan sa parehong
Quantum state ay ibinibigay ng ket s beses bra s tulad ng ipinapakita dito sa screen upang maging malinaw tungkol dito ang mga indeks ng s
ay tumutugma sa isang paraan sa mga classical State ng anumang sistema na pinag-uusapan natin at iyan ay eksakto ang parehong pagsusulatan na mayroon tayo sa pagitan ng
mga hilera at haligi ng aming density Matrix at ang mga classical state ng sistema kung iisipin natin na mayroon n
classical state ng sistema at iniisip natin ang mga column at row vector bilang mga matrix kung gayon ang ket s ay isang N baitang 1 Matrix
at ang bra s ay isang 1 baitang n Matrix kaya kapag ginaganap ang multiplication makakakuha tayo ng isang N baitang n
Matrix ito ay palaging magiging isang positive semi-definite Matrix dahil lang sa anyo nito at magkakaroon din ito ng Trace na katumbas ng
isa dahil sa katotohanan na ang s ay isang unit vector at makikita natin iyon nang mas detalyado
sa ilang sandali ang mga Quantum state na kinakatawan ng mga density matrix ng anyo na ito ay tinatawag na Pure
State narito ang ilang halimbawa una tingnan natin ang state na
ito na parang isang plus State maliban na ang entry na tumutugma sa classical State na isa ay
imaginary kung kukuha tayo ng conjugate transpose magkakaroon tayo ng minus sign dahil ang complex conjugate ng i ay
minus i at kung gagawin natin ang multiplication makakakuha tayo ng Matrix na ipinapakita dito sa screen ito ay Hermitian tulad ng
agad nating nakikita sa pagtingin lamang at nangyayari na ito ay mayroong isang eigenvalue na katumbas ng isa at isang eigenvalue na katumbas ng
zero kaya ito ay positive semi-definite at ang Trace nito ay katumbas ng isa kaya ito ay isang density Matrix tulad ng
inaasahan maaari tayong kalkulahin ang mga density matrix na tumutugma sa standard basis at sa plus minus na mga base sa katulad na paraan at ang mga density matrix na iyon
ay ipinapakita dito at narito ang isa pang halimbawa ng isang Quantum State Vector nangyari na
lumitaw ito noong una pa sa unang aralin ng serye at kung kukuha tayo ng conjugate transpose at pagkatapos ay i-multiply
makukuha natin ang density Matrix na ipinapakita dito muli ito ay Hermitian at may
Trace na katumbas ng isa at kung kukuha ng IG values makikita mo na muli ito ay may isang IG value na katumbas ng isa at isa
eigenvalue na katumbas ng zero at sa pamamagitan ng paraan iyan ay isang karaniwang katangian ng lahat ng Pure State palagi silang may isang eigenvalue
na katumbas ng isa at ang natitirang mga IG value ay lahat ay zero sa pangkalahatan para sa isang ganap na arbitrary na Quantum State
Vector s na may anumang bilang ng mga entry kung magmu-multiply tayo ng ket s sa bra s makakakuha tayo ng isang
density Matrix na mukhang ganito pansinin sa partikular na ang mga diagonal na entry ay palaging isa sa mga
entry ng s na pinarami sa sariling complex conjugate nito na maaari rin nating ipahayag bilang absolute value squared ng entry na iyon at ito ay
isang paraan ng pagtingin na ang trace ay palaging katumbas ng isa naaayon din ito sa puna na ginawa ko kanina sa aralin tungkol sa
mga diagonal na entry ng isang density Matrix na nagsasabi sa atin kung ano ang mga probabilidad upang makita ang bawat posibleng classical state
kung magsasagawa tayo ng standard basis measurement at isang huling puna doon
walang isyu tungkol sa mga Global phase para sa mga density matrix ang dalawang Quantum state ay magkapareho kung at tanging kung ang kanilang density
matrices ay pantay-pantay sa partikular ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong dalawang Quantum State vector s at fi na
katumbas hanggang sa isang global phase na nangangahulugang maaari tayong ipahayag ang isa sa kanila ang fi halimbawa bilang ang isa pang beses
ng ilang complex number sa unit circle kung kukuha tayo ng density Matrix na representasyon ng fi kung gayon ang makikita natin
ay ang global phase Factor ay pinarami sa sariling complex conjugate nito at nagbibigay sa atin ng isa kaya ito ay
epektibong nawawala at naiwan tayo ng eksakto parehong density Matrix na nakukuha natin mula sa s kaya iyon ay medyo isang
magandang maliit na bonus at sa pangkalahatan walang isyu tungkol sa katumbas hanggang sa mga Global phase sa lahat kapag tayo ay
nagtatrabaho sa mga density matrix iyon ay mahalagang isang degeneracy na umiiral kapag gumagamit tayo ng mga quantum State vector kaysa
sa mga density matrix upang kumatawan ng mga Quantum state ang mga density matrix ay nagtataglay ng isang pangunahing katangian na ang mga convex
combination ng mga density matrix ay kumakatawan ng mga probabilistic o random na pagpili ng quantum
State ang isa pang paraan ng pagsabi nito ay ang mga density matrix ay maaaring i-average nang magkasama sa isang makahulugang paraan na
hindi isang bagay na magagawa natin sa mga Quantum State vector upang ipaliwanag ito nang mas detalyado simulan tayo sa sitwasyon kung saan
mayroon tayong dalawang density matrix rho at sigma na kumakatawan ng mga Quantum state ng ilang sistema isipin natin na ang
sistema ay inihanda sa state rho na may probabilidad P para sa ilang pagpili ng P sa pagitan ng zero at isa at kung hindi
ang sistema ay inihanda sa state Sigma halimbawa maaaring ang p ay 1/2 kaya
maaari nating isipin na may nagbabato ng isang palaisipang barya at kung ulo ang lumabas magsasagawa sila ng ilang proseso na mag-iiwan sa sistema sa
state rho at kung hindi at buntot naman ang lumabas ng barya ay magsasagawa sila ng ibang proseso na mag-iiwan sa sistema sa
state Sigma ang tanong ngayon ay kung ano ang state ng sistema at upang maging malinaw
tayo ay interesado sa state ng sistema nang nag-iisa binalewala ang anumang iba pang impormasyon na maaaring umiiral tungkol sa
kung aling paghahanda ang ginawa halimbawa isipin na wala tayong access sa barya o sa
memorya ng sinumang nagsagawa ng paghahanda ng state at ang sagot sa tanong na iyon ay ito ay simpleng weighted average ng dalawa
density matrices P beses rho plus 1 minus P beses Sigma ito sa pamamagitan ng paraan ay ganap na
katulad ng mayroon sana tayo kung ang rho at sigma ay hindi density matrices kundi mga probability vector
na kumakatawan ng mga probabilistic state kaya hindi ito isang bagay na nakakagulat o misteryoso kundi ito ay isang bagay
na marahil ay pamilyar mula sa Probability Theory ginagawa natin ang ganitong uri ng pag-average palagi kapag kinakalkula natin ang mga probabilidad at nag-iisip
tungkol sa mga classical random na pagpili at ang punto ay ito rin ay gumagana para sa mga density matrix ngunit pansinin na ito ay
hindi gumagana para sa mga Quantum State vector ibig sabihin ay hindi mo karaniwang maaaring i-average nang magkasama ang dalawang Quantum State
vector tulad nito at umasa na makakakuha ng isang valid na Quantum State vector at kung susubukan mo ay karaniwang makakakuha ka ng isang vector na
walang Euclidean Norm na katumbas ng isa sa mga density matrix gayunman ang mga weighted average tulad nito ay palaging
magiging valid na density matrices at mas mahalaga pa ang density Matrix na makukuha mo ay kumakatawan ng random na pagpiling iyon sa isang
makahulugang paraan ito ay generalize sa mga random na pagpili kung saan mayroong higit sa dalawang
Alternatibo sa partikular kung mayroon tayong M posibleng density matrices at isang probability Vector na may M na entry isa
para sa bawat density Matrix at ang isang sistema ay inihanda sa bawat posibleng state na may kaukulang probabilidad
kung gayon ang weighted average ng mga density matrix na iyon ay naglalarawan ng resultang state ng sistema at sa pamamagitan ng paraan kapag
tinutukoy natin ang isang convex combination ng mga density matrix ito ang ibig sabihin natin ang isang convex combination ay simpleng isang linear
combination kung saan ang mga coefficient ay bumubuo ng isang probability Vector ito ay palaging magiging isang density
Matrix at ang isang simple at maigting na paraan ng pagsabi nito sa mathematical na termino ay ang set ng lahat ng density matrix
na tumutugma sa isang ibinigay na sistema ay isang convex set kaya kung mayroon tayong sabihin m Quantum State
vector na s0 hanggang s M minus isa kasama ang mga probabilidad p 0 hanggang p m minus isa na sama-samang bumubuo ng isang
probability vector at ang isang sistema ay inihanda sa state s k na may probabilidad PK para sa bawat k kung gayon ang
resultang state ng sistema ay inilalarawan ng density Matrix na ipinapakita dito sa screen sa partikular hindi tayo nag-a-average nang magkasama
ng mga quantum State vector mismo kundi nag-a-average tayo ng magkasama ang mga kaukulang density
matrices sa pangkalahatan ang isang state tulad nito ay walang representasyon bilang isang solong Quantum State
Vector maliban na may trivial na nangyayari tulad ng lahat ng quantum State vector ay katumbas hanggang sa isang global phase o lahat maliban sa isa ng
mga probabilidad ay zero hindi tayo makakakuha ng isang pure Quantum state mula sa ganitong proseso sa halip makakakuha tayo ng tinatawag na
mixed Quantum state kung saan mayroon na mga likas na kawalan ng katiyakan tingnan natin ang isang simpleng
halimbawa ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong isang cubit at na may probabilidad 1/2 ang Cubit ay inihanda sa zero State at kung hindi
ito ay inihanda sa plus State narito ang density Matrix na makukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pag-average tulad ng aking
inilarawan kina-compute natin ang mga density matrix na tumutugma sa dalawang posibleng state pinarami sa mga kaukulang probabilidad at idagdag ang
mga resulta ang nakuha natin ay talagang isang density matrix ito ay Hermitian ang trace nito ay katumbas ng isa
at kung kukuha mo ng mga eigenvalue ng matrix na ito makakakuha ka ng dalawang positibong tunay na numero at nangyayari na ang mga ito ay dalawang numero na dapat na pamilyar na sa iyo
sa ngayon cosine squared ng pi over 8 at sin squared ng pi over 8 o mga 0.85 at
0.15 walang solong Quantum State Vector na representasyon ng state hindi ito isang pure state susunod ay titingnan natin ang isa
partikular na density Matrix na kumakatawan sa isang Quantum state ng isang single Cubit na kilala bilang completely mixed
state madalas na lumilitaw ang state kaya maganda na magkaroon ng pangalan para dito at ito rin ay isang magandang halimbawa dahil ito
ay nagpapakita ng isang mahalagang katangian ng mga density matrix mayroon sa katunayan na isang katulad na tinutukoy na completely mixed state para sa anumang
sistema ngunit sa ngayon ay magtutuon tayo sa state na ito para sa isang single Cubit basta upang mapanatiling simple ang mga bagay
ipagpalagay na random nating itinakda ang state ng isang cubit upang maging alinman sa zero State o ang one state bawat isa ay may
probabilidad na katumbas ng 1/2 halos katulad ng isang uniform random bit maaari tayong kalkulahin ang density Matrix na representasyon ng state na ito
sa karaniwang paraan kinukuha natin ang average ng dalawang density Matrix na representasyon ng mga state narito kung paano
iyan mukhang sa Matrix na anyo at ang nakukuha natin ay ang identity Matrix na hinati sa
dalawa ang state na ito ay kilala bilang completely mixed state at ito ay mahalagang kumakatawan ng kumpleto o maximal
na kawalan ng katiyakan tungkol sa isang cubit halos katulad ng isang uniform probability Vector ay kumakatawan ng maximal na kawalan ng katiyakan sa
classical probabilistic na setting sa pangkalahatan para sa isang arbitrary na sistema ang completely mixed state ay ang
state na makukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng uniformly pagpili ng isang standard basis State at ang density Matrix na representasyon ay magiging ang
identity Matrix na hinati sa dimension o katumbas ang bilang ng mga classical state ng sistema na iyon
sa puntong ito ito ay terminolohiya lamang ngunit kung magbabago tayo ng setup ng kaunti makikita natin ang isang mahalagang katangian ng
mga density matrix sa partikular ipagpalagay na binago natin ang pamamaraan at sa
halip ng mga zero at one standard basis State pinalitan natin ang plus at minus State sa pagkakataong ito nagsisimula tayo sa
ekspresyon na ipinapakita sa screen ngunit kung dadaan tayo sa aritmetika makukuha natin ang eksakto parehong
density matrix ito ay ang identity Matrix na hinati sa dalawa kaya ito ay parehong state tulad ng dati ang
completely mixed state ito gaya ng sinasabi nila ay isang katangian at hindi isang bug ang dalawang pamamaraan ay talagang
magkaiba ngunit kung ang mayroon ka lamang ay ang resultang Cubit walang pisikal na paraan na posible mong makilala ang mga ito
kahit sa statistical na paraan halimbawa kung nagsagawa ka ng standard basis measurement sa cubit na ito
pagkatapos ng unang pamamaraan ay malinaw na makakakuha ka ng kinalabasan na zero na may probabilidad 1/2 at ang kinalabasan na isa na may probabilidad 1/2 ngunit makukuha mo rin ang
eksakto parehong mga probabilidad ng kinalabasan para sa pangalawang pamamaraan at ganoon din para sa anumang iba pang pagsubok na maaaring
gawin mo sa basta sinusubok mo lang ang Cubit mismo sa pangkalahatan ang mga density matrix ay hindi naglalarawan kung paano inihanda ang isang sistema
sinasabi lamang nila sa iyo kung ano ang mangyayari kung gagawa ka ng mga bagay sa sistema na papunta kung isinasagawa mo man
ng mga operasyon o mga sukat at sa katunayan ang mga density matrix ay perpekto sa bagay na ito
kung ang dalawang magkaibang Alternatibo ay nagresulta sa parehong density Matrix hindi sila maaaring mapagkilala kahit
sa statistical ngunit kung ang dalawang density matrix ay magkaiba kung gayon may paraan upang mapagkilala sila hindi
naman palagi nang tiyak ngunit sa statistical na paraan kapag gumagamit tayo ng pangkalahatang pormulasyon ng quantum
information ang classical na impormasyon ay mahalagang lumalabas bilang isang espesyal na kaso at ipapaliwanag ko ngayon kung paano iyon
gumagana partikular makikita natin kung paano ang mga probabilistic state ay maaaring kumatawan ng mga density
matrices magsimula tayo sa mga classical State simula sa isang simpleng
halimbawa narito ang mga density Matrix na representasyon ng zero at one standard basis state ng isang
cubit iuugnay natin ang mga state na ito sa mga classical State 0 at isa kaya maaari tayong mag-isip tungkol sa mga density matrix na ito bilang
kumakatawan ng mga state na iyon iyon ay napaka-simple at madali tayong makapag-generalize ng
halimbawa kung mayroon tayong sistema na ang classical State set ay Sigma kung gayon ang classical State a ay kinakatawan ng o
ay nauugnay sa density Matrix na ket a bra a ang Matrix na iyon ay may isang isa sa diagonal
na entry na ang hilera at haligi ay tumutugma sa classical State a at ang bawat iba pang entry ay
zero ang mga probabilistic state ay kinakatawan ng mga convex combination ng mga matrix ng anyo na ito na natural
dahil sa alam natin tungkol sa mga density matrix at kung paano sila gumagana partikular na ang mga convex combination ng mga density matrix ay kumakatawan ng random o
probabilistic na mga pagpili ng mga quantum State halimbawa ipagpalagay na
mayroon tayong sistema X na ang classical State set ay kinabibilangan ng mga integer 0 hanggang n minus isa para sa ilang positibong integer n ng
siyempre maliit o walang generalidad na nawawala sa pagpapalagay na ang aming classical State set ay may ganitong anyo kung mayroon tayong isang
iba't ibang classical State set maaari nating palitan ang pangalan ng mga classical State sa ganitong paraan at madalas na medyo maginhawa ang gumawa ng palagay na ang aming
mga classical State set ay mukhang ganito sa malaking bahagi dahil ginagawa nitong mas madaling isulat ang mga bagay nang malinaw sa mga tuntunin ng
mga vector at matrix ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong probabilistic state ng sistema X
na kinakatawan ng isang probability Vector sa karaniwang paraan maaari nating iugnay ang probabilistic state na ito sa isang density
Matrix tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen kinukuha natin ang weighted average ng mga density matrix na tumutugma sa
iba't ibang classical State at ang nakukuha natin ay isang diagonal density Matrix sa partikular nakikita natin ang mga probabilidad
sa diagonal ng Matrix na ito at ang bawat iba pang entry ay katumbas ng zero siyempre ito ay isang density Matrix
inaasahan natin iyon ngunit maaari rin nating matuwiran ito nang direkta ito ay isang Hermitian matrix ang Trace nito
ay katumbas ng isa dahil ang probabilidad ay kabuuanng isa at sa kaso ng isang diagonal matrix ang mga eigenvalue ay ang diagonal
na mga entry at lahat sila ay hindi negatibo dahil sila ay mga probabilidad din pansinin na ang bawat
diagonal density Matrix na nangangahulugang isa na ang lahat ng off diagonal na entry ay zero ay dapat magmukhang ganito kaya sa maikling salita
ang mga probabilistic state ay maaaring iugnay sa mga diagonal density matrices pansinin sa pamamagitan ng paraan na ito ay naaayon sa
impormal na interpretasyon ng mga entry ng density matrices na nabanggit ko sa simula ng aralin sa partikular walang anumang bagay sa
Quantum superposition dito ito ay mahalagang classical Randomness lamang at kaugnay nito ang lahat ng off diagonal
na entry ay zero kanina sa seryeng ito tinalakay natin ang spectral theorem at ginawa natin iyon
partikular para sa mga unitary matrix sa konteksto ng phase estimation ang spectral theorem ay mas
pangkalahatan kaysa rito gayunpaman ibig sabihin ay nagsasabi ito sa atin ng isang bagay tungkol sa isang mas malawak na klase ng mga matrix kaysa sa mga unitary lamang
matrix at sa partikular ito ay naaangkop sa isang klase ng mga matrix na tinatawag na normal na mga matrix na kinabibilangan ng lahat ng mga matrix bilang
gayundin ang mga unitary matrix ang gagawin natin ngayon ay tingnan ang ibang pahayag ng theorem na ito sa pagkakataong ito nakatuon lamang sa
mga positive semi-definite na matrice at pagkatapos ay makikita natin na nagsasabi ito sa atin ng isang napaka-interesante at kritikal na mahalaga tungkol sa density
matrices ipagpalagay ang p ay anumang positive semi-definite Matrix kaya kasama na rito ang anumang density Matrix gayundin ang anumang
positive semi-definite Matrix na hindi nangyayaring may Trace na katumbas ng isa ang p ay positive semi-definite kaya kailangan nito
na maging square o sa madaling salita N baitang n para sa ilang pagpili ng N at kakailanganin nating sumangguni sa bilang na n kaya hayaan ang N na
mapili nang naaangkop o ang isa pang paraan ng pagsabi ng lahat ng ito ay ipagpalagay na ang p ay n baitang n kung ano ang sinasabi sa atin ng theorem sa kasong ito ay na
dapat ay mayroon isang orthonormal na base ng mga vector na pananganlan nating s0 hanggang S n minus isa kasama ang mga hindi negatibong tunay na
numero na Lambda 0 hanggang Lambda n minus isa na ang P ay maaaring ipahayag tulad ng ipinapakita
dito sa screen sa mga salita kung magmu-multiply tayo ng bawat Lambda K sa ket k beses bra k at pagkatapos ay
ibuo sa lahat ng K mula 0 hanggang n minus isa makukuha natin ang P ito ay tinatawag na spectral
decomposition ng P ang bawat Lambda K ay kinakailangang isang eigenvalue ng p at ang bawat s ay isang unit eigenvector ng P
na tumutugma sa eigenvalue na iyon kung babalikan mo ang aralin 7 sa phase estimation makikita mo ang katulad na theorem
para sa mga unitary matrix doon ang mga eigenvalue ay mga complex number sa unit circle kaysa sa pagiging mga hindi negatibong tunay na
numero ngunit kung hindi man ay parehong ideya at ang mga ito ay talagang dalawang espesyal na kaso ng isang mas Pangkalahatang theorem na kilala bilang
ang spectral theorem hindi ito gumagana para sa bawat Matrix kailangan mo ang Matrix na mag-commute sa sarili nitong
conjugate transpose at iyan ang ibig sabihin para sa isang matrix na maging normal ngunit sa katunayan lagi nating mayroon
iyon para sa parehong mga unitary matrix at mga positive semi-definite matrix at para sa mga Hermitian matrix nang mas pangkalahatan kung saan
lagi tayong magkakaroon ng tunay na eigenvalue ngunit hindi kinakailangan na mga hindi negatibo kaya iyon ay isang pahayag ng
spectral theorem para sa mga positive semi-definite matrix lamang at ngayon tingnan natin kung ano ang sinasabi nito sa atin tungkol sa density
matrices kung ano ang sinasabi nito sa atin ay na para sa isang arbitrary n baitang n density Matrix palagi nating maaaring ipahayag ang Matrix na iyon bilang isang convex
combination ng n pure State at bukod dito maaari nating kunin ang n pure state na iyon upang maging
orthogonal iyon ay sumusunod nang malinaw mula sa theorem kasama ang isang pangunahing katotohanang mula sa linear algebra na ang
kabuuan ng mga eigenvalue ng anumang matrix ay palaging katumbas ng trace ng matrix na iyon sa madaling salita ang lahat ng talagang ginagawa natin ay
ang palitan ang pangalan ng mga eigenvalue p 0 hanggang PN minus isa at pagkatapos ay mapansing kapag ginawa natin iyon at
kolektahin ang mga IG value na iyon sa isang n-dimensional na Vector ay kinakailangang makakakuha tayo ng isang probability Vector dahil lahat sila ay kailangang hindi negatibo at ang kabuuan ng mga ito ay katumbas
ng trace ng rho na isa dahil ang rho ay isang density Matrix kaya iyon ay medyo simple ngunit ito ay
talagang lubos na pundamental sa konsepto kung ano ang sinasabi nito sa atin ay na ang bawat density Matrix hindi
mahalaga kung gaano kito kumplikado ay maaaring lumabas mula sa unang pagpili ng isang orthonormal na base ng anumang sistema
na pinag-uusapan natin at pagkatapos ay random na pagpili ng isang Quantum state mula sa base na iyon Ayon sa ilang pagpili para sa prob
mga probabilidad kung hindi agad malinaw sa ibabaw kung bakit iyon ay interesante o mahalaga okey lang ngunit ginagamit natin ang
katotohanang ito nang madalas kapag nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa mga density matrix at sa katunayan ang pagpapahayag ng isang ibinigay na density Matrix
sa ganitong paraan ay madalas na ang unang bagay na ginagawa natin kapag gusto nating maunawaan ito
nang mas mabuti narito ang isang halimbawa alalahanin ang density Matrix na nalikha natin kanina kung saan random tayong pumili sa pagitan ng
zero State at ng plus State bawat isa ay may probabilidad 1/2 na gaya ng aming kinalkula ay may density Matrix na
mukhang ganito ang zero State at ang plus state ay hindi orthogonal kaya hindi ito isang
spectral decomposition ngunit kung kukuha tayo ng isa na magagawa natin sa pamamagitan ng isang computer o nang manu-mano sa ganitong kaso kung gayon ang makukuha natin
ay ang ekspresyon na ito ng aming density Matrix kung saan ang mga eigenvalue ay ang mga numerong patuloy na lumilitaw at
kung saan ang mga kaukulang eigenvector ay maaaring mapili tulad ng ipinapakita dito sa ibaba ng screen at muli nakita na natin ang mga vector na ito dati halimbawa sa
konteksto ng chsh game sa Aralin Apat kaya iyon ay interesante ayon sa
orihinal na ekspresyon ang state na ito ay makukuha sa pamamagitan ng uniformly pagpili sa pagitan ng dalawang state ang zero State at
ang plus state ngunit sa katunayan makukuha natin ang eksakto parehong density matrix sa pamamagitan ng random na pagpili sa pagitan ng dalawang pure
State ngunit talagang lubos na minamasama natin ang isa sa kanila mga 85% para sa una at mga 15% lamang para sa
pangalawa kaya sa ilang kahulugan ay talagang mas kaunti ang Randomness na likas sa state kaysa sa maaaring mukhang sa una
mayroong isang napakagandang geometric na paraan ng pag-iisip at pagbiswal ng mga Quantum state ng isang single Cubit na kilala
bilang block sphere gumagana lamang ito para sa mga single cubit para sa mga sistema na may tatlo
o higit pang classical State kabilang ang dalawa o higit pang cubit nang magkasama hindi na ito gumagana kaya ito ay medyo limitado ngunit
gayunpaman ito ay isang mahusay na paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol sa mga state ng isang single Cubit maaari sana itong ipakilala
noong una pa sa aralin isa ng serye sa mga single system ngunit hindi talaga ito mahalaga sa pag-unawa kung paano gumagana ang Quantum information at mayroon din itong isang
napakagandang koneksyon sa mga density matrix kaya natural itong naaayon sa araling ito at sa katunayan ipapaliwanag ko ito
sa isang medyo iba't ibang paraan kaysa sa madalas na pinaka-karaniwang ipinaliwanag sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng mga density matrix upang epektibo
na makuha ito kaya kung pamilyar ka na sa block sphere ang paliwanag na ito ay maaaring medyo iba sa
paraang unang natutunan mo ito ngunit sa katapusan siyempre katumbas ito magsisimula tayo sa pag-iisip tungkol sa
mga posibleng pure state ng isang cubit una tulad ng kinakatawan ng mga Quantum State
vector hanggang sa isang global phase ang bawat Cubit Quantum State Vector ay maaaring ipahayag bilang
ipinapakita dito sa screen upang maging tumpak mayroon tayong dalawang tunay na numero Theta at fi at mag-iisip tayo
tungkol sa dalawang numerong ito bilang mga anggulo na ipinahayag sa radians ang unang numero Theta ay nasa pagitan ng 0 at Pi o katumbas ay isang
anggulo sa pagitan ng 0 at 180° at ang pangalawang numero fi ay nasa pagitan ng 0 at 2 pi kabilang ang 0 ngunit hindi ang 2
pi kaya iyon ay anumang anggulo sa pagitan ng 0 at 360° ang Zero Entry ng aming Vector ay
cosine ng theta divided by 2 kaya iyon ay isang tunay na numero sa pagitan ng 0 at 1 at sa partikular ito ay kinakailangang hindi negatibo
at ang one entry ng aming Vector ay e sa kapangyarihan ng i beses fi beses sine ng th divided by 2 at maaari ito
maging anumang complex number sa o sa loob ng complex unit circle ito ay palaging isang unit vector o
sa madaling salita ito ay isang valid na Quantum State vector at para sa anumang ibinigay na cubit Quantum State Vector palagi tayong makakahanap
ng isang vector ng anyo na ito na katumbas ng Vector na iyon hanggang sa isang global phase sa partikular palagi tayong maaaring
i-multiply ang ibinigay na vector ng isang global phase upang gawin ang Zero Entry na isang hindi negatibong tunay na numero piliin kung anong
Theta ang gumagana upang ibigay sa atin ang entry na iyon at pagkatapos ay piliin ang fi upang tumugma sa one entry ang magnitude ng one entry ay
palaging kinakailangang sang-ayon sa sine ng theta divided by two sa pamamagitan ng palagay na nagsimula tayo sa isang unit
Vector ngayon hindi talaga ang kaso na ang Theta at fi ay natatanging tinutukoy ng anumang Quantum State Vector na sinimulan natin
ngunit halos ganoon palagi magkakaroon ng natatanging halaga ng theta sa pagitan ng zero at Pi na gumagana
at karaniwang mayroon ding natatanging halaga ng fi na gumagana ngunit sa dalawang espesyal na kaso hindi ito totoo sa partikular kung nagsimula tayo sa isang
standard basis State kung gayon ang Theta ay magiging alinman sa zero o pi at sa parehong kaso hindi talaga mahalaga kung ano ang fi ito ay
ganap na hindi kaugnay kapag ang Theta ay zero ang cosine ng theta divided by 2 ay 1 at ang sine ng theta divided by 2
ay zero kaya nagmu-multiply tayo ng e sa kapangyarihan ng i beses fi sa zero kaya hindi mahalaga kung ano ang fi
at kung ang Theta ay pi kung gayon sa pagkakataong ito ang cosine ay zero at ang sine ay isa kaya mayroon tayo ng e sa kapangyarihan ng i beses fi beses kat1 ngunit ang mga
vector na iyon ay lahat katumbas hanggang sa isang global phase kaya muli hindi mahalaga kung ano ang fi gayunpaman kung ang Theta ay nasa pagitan
ng Zero at Pi kung gayon palagi magkakaroon ng natatanging halaga ng fi na gumagana at sa pamamagitan ng paraan ang posibleng
degeneracy sa halaga ng fi para sa dalawang espesyal na kaso ay magiging perpektong malinaw kapag nakita na natin ang geometric na larawan sa
loob ng ilang sandali ngayon kalkulahin natin ang density Matrix na nauugnay sa isang State Vector ng anyo na aming katatapos na
tukuyin kaya ito ay magiging isang pure state ng isang cubit upang gawin ito pinarami natin ang vector
sa sariling conjugate transpose nito tulad ng dati at sa screen ay isang ekspresyon ng Matrix na makukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pag-compute ng
conjugate transpose at pagsasagawa ng multiplication ngayon tulad ng bawat 2x2
matrix mayroon natatanging paraan upang makuha ang matrix na ito sa pamamagitan ng pagkuha ng linear combination ng mga Pauli matrix
kabilang ang identity Matrix sa partikular maaari nating makuha ang matrix na ito sa pamamagitan ng pagpili ng mga coefficient ng
mga Pauli matrix tulad ng ipinapakita dito sa screen naglalagay tayo ng dalawa sa denominator dahil gagawin nitong
gumagana nang maayos ang lahat wala na puwersang gawin natin ito ngunit kaya natin at magiging kapaki-pakinabang ang gawin iyon ngunit sa gilid
ng kosmetikong Pagpiling ito walang kalayaan dito ito ang tanging paraan upang makuha ang matrix na ito sa pamamagitan ng pagkuha ng linear combination ng mga Pauli matrix
dahil ang mga Pauli matrix kabilang ang identity Matrix ay isang base para sa vector space ng lahat ng 2x2 na matrix ang isang paraan
upang suriin ang kawastuhan ng ekspresyong ito ay ang gumamit ng ilang pangunahing trigonometric na pagkakakilanlan at sa partikular kung aalis ako sa paraan para sa
ilang sandali dito ay mayroon tayong ilang mga pagkakakilanlan na gagawa ng lansihin kaya kung nais mo i-pause ang video o
kumuha ng screenshot at tingnan kung maaari mong makuha ang pangalawang ekspresyon ng density Matrix sa ibaba mula sa una kaya sa buod ang anumang pure state ng isang
cubit na ipinahahayag bilang isang density Matrix ay maaaring isulat bilang isang linear combination ng mga Pauli matrix tulad ng ipinapakita sa
screen para sa Theta sa pagitan ng 0 at pi at fi sa pagitan ng 0 at 2 pi pansinin na mayroon tayong eksakto ang parehong
degeneracy tulad ng dati na ang fi ay hindi kaugnay kapag ang Theta ay zero o pi at sa pagkakataong ito maaari natin
makita iyon nang mas malinaw dahil ang sine ng theta ay zero sa dalawang kasong iyon at kung hindi man ay hindi ito sulit na ituro
na sa formula na ito ang Theta ay lumalabas bilang argumento sa sine at cosine function kaysa sa Theta divided by 2 tulad ng sa orihinal na Quantum State
Vector na bersyon at iyon ay dahil ginamit natin ang mga trigonometric na pagkakakilanlan ang unang tatlo ay mahalagang
mga muling pagsasaayos ng tinatawag na double angle formulas kaya ang anggulo ay epektibong nagdoble at ngayon ay handa na tayo
na pag-usapan ang block sphere mismo tumuon tayo sa tatlong coefficient ng hindi identity na Pauli
matrix sa numerator ng ekspresyon ng aming density Matrix kaya hindi natin pinansin ang dalawa sa
denominator hindi rin natin pinansin ang identity Matrix dahil ang coefficient doon ay hindi kailanman nagbabago nangyayari iyon dahil
ang coefficient na iyon ay tinutukoy ng trace ng anumang Matrix na ipinapahayag natin at ang mga density matrix ay palaging may Trace na katumbas ng
isa ngayon isipin na mayroon tayong tatlong axis na may label na x y at z na nakahanay ayon sa
tinatawag na right-hand rule at isaalang-alang ang punto na ang mga coordinate ay tumutugma sa tatlong coefficient at upang maging malinaw ito ay
ordinaryong tatlong-dimensional na espasyo na pinag-uusapan natin kung saan ang mga coordinate ay palaging mga tunay na numero ang
x coordinate ay tumutugma sa coefficient ng sigma X na Pauli Matrix sa numerator ng aming ekspresyon na palaging isang tunay na numero dahil ang mga density
matrix ay Hermitian at gayundin para sa Y at Z kung ano ang nakikita natin ay ang puntong
nakukuha natin ay palaging nasa unit sphere o sa madaling salita ang sphere na may radius na katumbas ng
isa at sa partikular ito ang punto na makukuha natin kung magsisimula tayo sa puntong kung saan ang positibong z-axis ay tumatawid sa sphere
na maaari nating isipin bilang North Pole bumaba patungo sa positibong x-axis ng isang anggulo ng theta at pagkatapos
bumaling patungo sa positibong y-axis o sa madaling salita Silangan ng isang anggulo ng fi sa kontekstong ito ang anggulo Theta ay
tinatawag na polar angle na madaling matandaan dahil nagsisimula ito sa polo at ang fi ay tinatawag na azimuthal
angle at sama-sama ang dalawang anggulong ito ay kumakatawan ng spherical coordinates para sa mga punto sa unit sphere at kung
nais mo maaari ka ring hayaang mag-iba ang radius upang kumatawan ng arbitrary na mga punto sa tatlong-dimensional na espasyo ngunit dito nakatuon tayo sa mga punto sa
unit sphere kung saan ang radius ay katumbas ng isa maaari mo ring isipin ang Theta bilang kumakatawan ng latitude maliban na pupunta tayo
mula 0 hanggang 180° mula North Pole hanggang South Pole kaysa sa plus minus 90° mula sa equator at ang fi ay kumakatawan ng
longitude kung saan mahalagang tino-define natin ang prime meridian bilang ang Meridian na tumatawid sa positibong
x-axis kung katulad mo at mahirap tandaan kung alin ang latitude at alin ang longitude maaaring makatulong na alalahanin
na ang longitude ay tumutugma sa agwat na mas mahaba ang 2 pi kumpara sa
Pi sa anumang paraan ang puntong nakukuha natin sa unit sphere mula sa aming Cubit State Vector s sa pamamagitan ng pag-iisip tungkol sa mga coordinate sa ganitong
paraan ay ang block sphere na representasyon ng quantum state na tumutugma sa s at kapag iniisip natin ang kabuuang
tatlong-dimensional na unit sphere sa ganitong paraan nakukuha natin ang block sphere geometrically ito ay isang unit
sphere sa ordinaryong tatlong-dimensional na espasyo ngunit sa katunayan iyon ang geometry ng mga Cubit
State mayroon perpektong isa-sa-isang pagsusulatan dito ang bawat pure state ng isang cubit ay tumutugma sa isang natatanging punto sa
sphere at ang bawat punto sa sphere ay kumakatawan ng isang natatanging Cubit State hanggang sa isang global phase kapag nagtatrabaho tayo sa
Quantum State vector ang pagsusulatan na ito ay may iba pang mga pangalan sa pamamagitan ng paraan ito ay minsan ay tinatawag na Poincare sphere halimbawa
ngunit sa konteksto ng quantum information ito ay karaniwang tinutukoy bilang block sphere pansinin na ngayon ay maaari nating makita ang
degeneracy sa anggulo ng fi nang malinaw dahil ang longitude ay walang kahulugan sa North at South Poles ngunit bukod dito
sa mga polo ang bawat punto sa Mundo ay may natatanging coordinates sa mga tuntunin ng latitude at longitude at ang parehong bagay ay nangyayari dito kaya iyon ang kung paano
gumagana ang block sphere sa pangkalahatan ngayon tingnan natin ang ilang partikular na halimbawa ng mga Cubit State at
kung saan sila nakalagay sa Block sphere magsimula tayo sa standard basis ang mga ito ang mga puntong nakukuha natin
kapag ang polar angle Theta ay zero para sa zero State at Pi para sa one state ang mga ito ang dalawang kaso kung saan ang
azimuthal angle fi ay hindi kaugnay tulad ng tinalakay ko na maaari rin tayong ipahayag ang mga kaukulang density matrix bilang linear
combination ng mga Pauli matrix sa alinmang paraan malalaman natin na ang dalawang state na ito ay tumutugma sa North Pole at sa
South Pole ng block sphere ang zero state ay nasa itaas at ang one state ay nasa
ibaba susunod hanapin natin ang plus at minus state sa Block sphere muli maaari nating isipin tungkol sa
Quantum State vector o sa mga density matrix para sa Quantum State vector sa pagkakataong ito ang polar angle Theta ay dapat na Pi
divided by 2 upang makuha ang Zero Entry na maging 1 divided by square root ng 2 ang azimuthal angle fi ay dapat na zero
para sa plus State dahil ang one entry ay positibo para sa plus State at kailangan itong maging Pi o 180° para sa minus State
dahil ang isa ay negatibo sa kasong iyon kaya ang dalawang puntong ito ay nakalagay sa
equator ng block sphere ang plus state ay kung saan ang positibong x-axis ay tumatawid sa sphere at ang minus state ay nasa kabilang panig kung saan ang
negatibong x-axis ay tumatawid sa sphere katumbas din ay maaari nating makita mula sa mga Pauli matrix na ekspresyon para sa
mga kaukulang density matrix na ang Y at Z coordinate ay parehong zero samantalang ang mga x coordinate ay positibo at negatibong
isa ang isa pang halimbawa ay ang plus I minus I basis na katulad ng plus minus basis maliban na pinarami rin natin ang
one entry ng i ang imaginary unit nakita natin ang plus I State kanina sa aralin at ang minus I state ay tinukoy
sa katulad na paraan ang polar angle Theta ay pareho tulad noong para sa plus at minus State na pi divided by
2 at sa pagkakataong ito kailangan nating piliin ang azimuthal angle fi upang makuha ang i at negatibong i kaysa sa 1 at negatibong 1
at ang Pi divided by 2 at 3 Pi divided by 2 ang tamang mga pagpipilian upang mangyari iyon muli maaari rin tayong tingnan ang
mga density Matrix na paglalarawan ng mga state na ito at ang mga bagay ay medyo katulad sa dalawang nakaraang halimbawa maliban na ngayon ito ay ang Pauli y Matrix sa halip
ng Z o X kaya sa Block sphere ang dalawang state na ito ay matatagpuan kung saan ang y-axis
ay tumatawid sa sphere at kung malilinis natin ang mga bagay ay mas malinaw nating makikita kung paano ang anim na State na talakayin natin
ay may kaugnayan sa isa't isa para sa isa pang halimbawa o talagang isang klase ng mga halimbawa isaalang-alang ang
Cubit State vector na lumitaw kanina at sa Aralin Apat kung saan ang Zero Entry ay cosine ng alpha para sa ilang tunay na numero Alpha at ang isa
entry ay sine ng alpha maaari nating i-restrict ang ating pansin sa mga halaga ng alpha sa pagitan ng zero at Pi dahil anumang
iba pang halaga ng alpha ay magbibigay sa atin ng vector na katumbas hanggang sa isang global phase sa isa kung saan ang Alpha ay nasa ganitong
hanay kung kukuha tayo ng mga density matrix na nauugnay sa mga state na ito na ipinahahayag bilang mga linear combination ng mga Pauli matrix
makukuha natin ang ekspresyon na ipinapakita dito sa screen ang kalkulasyong iyon ay hindi ipinapakita dito ngunit iyon ang dapat mong
makuha kung dadaan ka dito at nakikita natin na ang mga state na ito ay bumubuo ng tinatawag na great circle na pumupunta
sa mga polo partikular na nagsisimula sa North Pole kapag ang Alpha ay zero papababa sa prime meridian at
tumutugma sa South Pole kapag ang Alpha ay pi over 2 at pagkatapos ay bumalik sa North Pole sa kabilang panig ng sphere habang ang Alpha ay nag-iikot mula pi over 2 hanggang
Pi at lahat ng iyon ay makatuwirang dahil una ang mga ito ay mga tunay na vector kaya ang imaginary na bahagi ay palaging zero at
pangalawa ang anggulo ng Alpha ay epektibong nagdoble sa Block sphere at muli maaari itong ipaliwanag sa pamamagitan ng paggamit
ng mga double angle formula nakita natin na ang block sphere ay nagbibigay ng isang napakagandang geometric na representasyon para sa mga pure state ng isang
cubit kung saan ang bawat punto sa sphere ay tumutugma sa isang natatanging pure state ng isang cubit at vice
versa kapag tinutukoy natin ang block ball tinutukoy natin ang lahat ng mga punto sa Block sphere gayundin ang mga punto
na nakapaloob sa loob nito ang mga punto sa loob ng block ball ay tumutugma rin sa Cubit State
partikular ang mga state na hindi pure State kaya sa madaling salita ang mga ito ay mga Cubit state na maaaring kinakatawan ng mga density matrix ngunit hindi ng Cubit State
vector ang isang pundamental na aspeto ng block ball at ang paraan ng pagkakatawan ng mga interior point ng mga impure State ay ang
mga convex combination ng mga punto sa loob ng block ball ay tumutugma sa mga convex combination ng mga density matrix
sa intuitive na pagsasalita nangangahulugan ito na ang geometry ay patuloy na gumagana nang perpekto kahit sa loob ng block
ball tingnan natin ang ilang halimbawa simula sa center point ng block ball na kumakatawan sa
completely mixed state ang completely mixed state ay nakukuha sa pamamagitan ng pag-average ng zero at one state na naaayon sa katotohanan
na ang center ng sphere ay eksakto sa kalagitnaan ng North Pole at South Pole at sa katunayan ito ay sa kalagitnaan ng anumang dalawang antipodal na punto tulad ng
ang plus at minus State at ang plus I at minus I State ang mga antipodal na punto sa block sphere ay palaging tumutugma sa
mga orthogonal Pure State at kung ano ang inihahayag o repleksyon nito ay maaari nating palaging isulat ang completely mixed state
bilang average sa pagitan ng anumang dalawang orthogonal pure Cubit State ang isa pang paraan ng pagtingin dito ay ang
pag-iisip tungkol sa Pauli Matrix na representasyon ng completely mixed state upang gumana ito kailangan nating itakda
ang mga coefficient sa lahat ng tatlong hindi identity na Pauli matrix upang maging zero at kaya ang kaukulang Punto sa loob ng
block ball ay eksakto sa center sa pinagmulan at sa pamamagitan ng paraan ang pag-iisip tungkol sa mga Pauli Matrix na representasyon ng density
matrices tulad nito ay talagang nagiging malinaw na ang mga convex combination ng mga block ball na punto ay tumutugma sa mga convex
combination ng mga density matrix kung kukuha tayo ng average o weighted average ng mga density matrix at
ipahayag ang lahat sa mga tuntunin ng mga linear combination ng mga Pauli matrix kung gayon siyempre nag-a-average lamang tayo ng mga kaukulang punto dahil ang lahat ay
linear sa tatlong coefficient na iyon para sa isa pang halimbawa isaalang-alang ang average ng zero State
at ng plus state na nakita natin kanina sa aralin kinalkula natin ang density Matrix na representasyon na ipinapakita sa
screen at ang punto ay nasa loob ng block ball sa kalagitnaan ng zero at plus
State nakita rin natin na maaari nating ipahayag ang density Matrix na ito sa ibang paraan batay sa spectral decomposition nito at
muli iyon ay naaayon sa diagram at sa mga nakaraang halimbawa at iyon ang nagwawakas ng
talakayan ng block sphere at block ball madalas na nagtatanong ang mga tao kung mayroong block sphere o block ball para sa mga sistema na may
tatlo o higit pang classical State at ang hindi magandang sagot ay hindi talaga palagi nating maaaring pag-isipan ang
mga quantum state ng isang sistema sa geometric na mga termino na katulad ng Block ball at makakakuha tayo ng isang convex body sa isang tunay na Vector
space ngunit kung mayroon tayong tatlo o higit pang classical State hindi ito magiging spherical halimbawa kung mayroon tayong
eksakto tatlong classical State o isang qutrit para sa maikli makakakuha tayo ng isang convex body sa isang walo-dimensional
na espasyo ngunit ang mga extreme na punto ng katawan na iyon na tumutugma sa mga pure Quantum state ng isang qutrit ay magiging
apat na dimensional lamang kung maaari mong biswal na makita ang pagkuha ng isang apat-dimensional na manifold sa isang walo-dimensional na espasyo at kahit papaano ay nag-shrink wrap ito upang makakuha ng isang convex
body at napakatulong nito para sa pag-iisip tungkol sa mga qutrit kung gayon higit na kapangyarihan sa iyo Guess na ito ay kawili-wili
na isipin ngunit hindi ito isang bola mas kumplikado ito kaysa doon sa huling bahagi ng aralin ay maikling tatalakayin natin
kung paano gumagana ang mga density matrix para sa maraming sistema ang mga density matrix ay maaaring kumatawan ng mga state ng maraming sistema at ito ay
gumagana sa isang ganap na katulad na paraan sa mga Quantum State vector sa partikular tulad ng nasa pinasimpleng pormulasyon ng quantum
information maaari tayong tingnan ang maraming sistema nang magkasama na parang sila ay mga single compound
system sa pagkakataong ito parehong mga hilera at haligi ng mga density matrix na kumakatawan ng mga state ng maraming sistema ay
inilagay sa pagsusulatan sa Cartesian product ng mga classical State set ng mga indibidwal na sistema halimbawa maaari nating isaalang-alang ang
mga density Matrix na representasyon ng apat na Bell state na nakukuha natin nang eksakto tulad ng ginawa natin para sa ibang Quantum
State vector kanina sa aralin sa pamamagitan ng pagmumultiply ng mga State vector sa kanilang mga conjugate transpose at ang mga resulta ay ipinapakita dito sa
screen sa esensya walang talaga bagong konsepto kahit na mababakas natin sa ilang sandali na mayroon mga ilang
bagong bagay na maaari nating gawin sa mga density matrix para sa maraming sistema ang mga Nosyon ng Kalayaan at
correlations ay inililipat mula sa mga Quantum State vector patungo sa mga density matrix at sa partikular nakikita natin na ang mga tensor product
ng mga density matrix ay kumakatawan ng Kalayaan sa pagitan ng mga sistema ginagamit natin ang parehong terminolohiya na
ginamit natin para sa mga Quantum State vector halimbawa kung mayroon tayong sistema X na inihanda sa isang state rho at isang sistema y
na independiyenteng inihanda sa isang state Sigma kung gayon ang state ng pares XY nang magkasama ay ibinibigay ng tensor product
ng rho at sigma tinatawag natin itong product State at ito ay generalize sa natural na paraan sa higit sa dalawang
sistema ang mga density matrix na hindi maaaring ipahayag bilang mga product State ay kumakatawan ng mga correlation sa pagitan ng mga sistema at ang
bahaging iyon ay katulad ng mga Quantum State vector ngunit tulad ng lumabas ay may iba't ibang uri ng correlations na maaaring lumabas kapag gumagamit tayo ng density matrices kahit para sa
dalawang sistema lamang sa kabilang dako mayroon talagang isang uri lamang ng correlation na maaari nating magkaroon para sa mga Quantum State vector at
iyon ay entanglement upang sabihin ito sa ibang paraan ang correlation at entanglement ay magkasingkahulugan para sa mga Quantum State vector ngunit
hindi iyon totoo para sa mga density matrix dito ang mga bagay ay mas interesante halimbawa maaari tayong maglarawan ng
mga correlated classical state gamit ang mga density matrix narito ang isang halimbawa ng isang density Matrix na kumakatawan ng isang classical random
bit na ibinabahagi sa pagitan nina Alice at Bob palagi silang may parehong classical State na Zero o isa at ang probabilidad ay
1/2 para sa bawat isa sa mga posibilidad hindi ito isang entangled State ang entanglement ay hindi classical ngunit
ito ay isang correlated na state ang isa pang halimbawa ay nauugnay sa konsepto ng ensemble ng mga quantum state
na maaari mong isipin bilang isang probability distribution sa isang finite na set ng mga quantum State sa partikular isipin natin na
mayroon tayong M density matrices rho zero hanggang rho M minus isa na lahat kumakatawan ng mga posibleng state ng isang partikular na sistema
kasama ang isang probabilidad upang makuha ang bawat isa kung nais natin ay maaari tayong kalkulahin ang weighted average ng mga density matrix na ito
sa pamamagitan ng pagkuha ng isang convex combination ng mga ito ngunit hindi talaga iyon sasabihin sa atin kung ano ang mga indibidwal na state o kung ano
ang mga probabilidad kung ano ang magagawa natin sa halip at medyo kapaki-pakinabang na gawin ito minsan ay isaalang-alang ang isang density
Matrix ng anyo na ipinapakita dito sa screen ito ay isang state ng dalawang sistema kung saan ang unang sistema ay may isang classical
state para sa bawat isa sa mga Alternatibo at kinukuha natin ang weighted average ng M product state kung saan ang state ng
unang sistema ay palaging classical at mahalagang nag-la-label kung alin sa m State ang mayroon tayo para sa pangalawang
sistema kung hindi malinaw eksakto kung bakit nais nating isipin ang tungkol sa mga State tulad nito okey lang ito ay isang halimbawa lamang ng
isang uri ng correlation kung saan ang unang sistema ay palaging classical at ang pangalawang sistema ay maaaring nasa isang Quantum
State ang ikatlong kategorya ng mga posibleng correlated na State ay ang set ng tinatawag na separable
State sa simpleng mga termino ang mga ito ay mga convex combination ng mga product State at mahalagang kinakatawan ng mga ito ang mga Quantum
state kung saan ang anumang correlations sa pagitan ng mga sistema ay mga classical correlations ang isang paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol sa
mga State tulad nito ay na gumagawa tayo ng probabilistic na pagpili para sa isang numero K at pagkatapos ay independiyenteng naghahanda ng dalawang
sistema sa isang Quantum state na maaaring depende sa pagpiling ito ng K kung ano ang marahil pinakainteresante tungkol sa
mga state ng anyo na ito ay ito ay talagang kung paano natin tino-define ang entanglement sa mathematical na mga termino sa partikular ang entanglement ay
tinukoy bilang kakulangan ng separability kaya kung mayroon kang isang density Matrix at hindi posible na ipahayag ito sa isang anyo
tulad nito kung gayon sa kahulugan ito ay entangled inudyukan ko ito noong Aralin Apat at narito ito nang medyo
mas detalyado sa pamamagitan ng paraan maaaring maging napakahirap na alamin kung ang isang ibinigay na density Matrix ay kumakatawan ng isang entangled
State kahit sa tulong ng isang computer sa mathematical at computational na pagsasalita ang entanglement ay
talagang medyo kumplikado nabanggit ko sa simula ng aralin na may isang napakahalagang bagay na magagawa natin sa mga density matrix at
iyon ay ang ilarawan ang mga state ng mga nakahiwalay na bahagi ng mga sistema kahit na sila ay magkakaugnay at posibleng entangled sa iba
mga sistema ang terminong reduce state ay madalas na ginagamit sa kontekstong ito at bilang isang simpleng halimbawa kalkula natin ang reduced
State para sa mga indibidwal na cubit na bumubuo ng isang ebit upang maging tumpak ipagpalagay na
ang Alice at Bob ay nagbabahagi ng isang ebit si Alice ay nagtataglay ng isang cubit A si Bob ay nagtataglay ng isang cubit B at sama-sama ang dalawang cubit na ito ay nasa isang phi
plus State at ang tanong na tatalakayin natin ay kung ano ang state ng Cubit A ni Alice sa
pagkakabukod siyempre maaari tayong magtanong ng parehong tanong para sa Cubit ni Bob ngunit madali itong sagutin kapag alam na natin ang sagot dito
ngayon maaaring matukso tayong sabihin na hindi natin maaaring ilarawan ang state ng cubit ni Alice nang nag-iisa dahil ito ay
entangled sa Cubit ni Bob na maaaring kahit papaano ay magbawal sa atin mula sa paglalarawan o maging pag-iisip tungkol sa state ng A sa
pagkakabukod ngunit ito ay mali totoo na hindi natin maaaring ilarawan ang state ng A gamit ang isang Quantum State
Vector dahil tulad ng makikita natin hindi ito nasa isang pure state ngunit ang bawat sistema ay may state anumang oras na maaaring
ilarawan ng isang density Matrix maging ito ay entangled sa isa pang sistema o hindi bilang isang thought experiment basta
upang matulungan tayong makita kung ano ang sagot sa tanong na ito ipagpalagay na nagpasya si Bob na kunin ang kanyang Cubit at maglakbay sa mga bituin at hindi na siya naririnig
muli ngunit isipin na sa daan ay nagpasya siyang magsagawa ng standard basis measurement sa kanyang
Cubit well alam natin kung paano kalkulahin ang mga probabilidad para sa kanya upang makuha ang dalawang posibleng kinalabasan at alam din natin kung ano ang
state ng A para sa bawat posibleng kinalabasan at ang mga bagay na iyon ay buod sa talahanayan na ito sa partikular na may probabilidad 1/2
ang A ay matitirang nasa zero State at na may probabilidad 1/2 ang A ay matitirang nasa one state at kaya gaya ng tinalakay kanina sa
aralin iniiiwan nito ang A sa completely mixed State at samakatuwid iyon ang sagot
sa ating tanong ngayon maaari kang tumutol at sabihing ito ay nakasalalay sa katotohanang
nagpasya si Bob na sukatin ang kanyang Cubit at ang palagay na ginagawa niya ito ay bahagi ng kwento na humantong sa atin sa sagot ngunit
kung si Bob ay maraming light years na ang layo sa panahon na sinusukat niya wala siyang magagawa na posibleng maaaring magkaroon ng anumang impluwensya sa anumang
eksperimento na maaaring pagpasyahan ni Alice na gawin sa kanyang Cubit kung hindi ay magkakaroon tayo ng faster than light
communication kaya ang Cubit ni Alice ay nasa completely mixed state anuman kung si Bob ay
sumusukat o hindi dapat kong gawing malinaw sa puntong ito na ang konsepto ng isang reduced State at ang paraan na sila ay tinukoy ay walang tunay na anumang pagdepende sa relatibidad
o imposibilidad ng faster than light communication ito ay isang paraan lamang upang maipaliwanag ito sa sana ay intuitive na mga termino
sa katunayan may isang mathematical na kahulugan na makikita natin sa isang mas Pangkalahatang konteksto sa ilang sandali naaayon ito sa sagot na ito
at koinsidensiyang naaayon din sa imposibilidad ng faster than light communication at wala ring iba
na kahulugan na maaaring maging naaayon sa Quantum information ayon sa ating kaalaman ngayon isaalang-alang natin ang mga reduced State sa mas Pangkalahatang
generality ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong pares ng mga sistema A at B hindi kinakailangang mga cubit na magkasama ay nasa isang pure State
na kinakatawan ng isang Quantum State Vector s muli ay magtutuon tayo sa reduce state ng sistema a at upang gawin
ito magiging kapaki-pakinabang na isipin ang tungkol sa mga classical state ng sistema B kaya hayaan ang gamma na maging ang set ng
mga classical state ng b gaya ng tinalakay natin dati noong aralin dalawa ng serye halimbawa
mayroong natatanging koleksyon ng mga vector fi b para sa bawat B sa Gamma para sa kung saan ang ekspresyon ng s na ipinapakita sa screen
ay tama at sa partikular mayroong simpleng formula para sa mga vector na ito simpleng pinarami natin ang vector s ng tensor
product ng identity Matrix na tumutugma sa sistema a kasama ang bra B para sa anumang B na interesado tayo
kung ano ang ginagawa natin dito ay mahalagang itinatakda nating sarili upang kalkulahin kung ano ang mangyayari kung magsasagawa tayo ng
standard basis measurement sa B at muli ito ay tinalakay sa aralin dalawa ng
serye kaya ipagpalagay na nagsagawa tayo ng standard basis measurement sa B ang bawat posibleng kinalabasan ay
lilitaw na may probabilidad na katumbas ng Euclidean norm squared ng kaukulang Vector fi b at kung ang kinalabasan ay
isang partikular na B na-normalize natin ang vector fi B upang matukoy ang resultang state ng
a ayon sa parehong pangangatwiran tulad ng sa halimbawa ng ebit mula kaaalis pa lamang makukuha natin ang ekspresyon na ipinapakita sa
screen para sa reduced state ng a bilang isang density Matrix at sa pamamagitan ng paraan ang norm squared sa denominator ay nagmumula sa
pagmumultiply ng normalized na vector sa sariling conjugate transpose nito kaya nakukuha natin ang Euclidean norm nang dalawang beses sa
denominator ang mga Euclidean Norm squared ay nagkakansela at naiwan tayo ng medyo simpleng
ekspresyon at sa katunayan kung ipinasok natin ang aming formula para sa fi B na gumagana para sa bawat B nakakakuha tayo ng formula para sa reduced
state ng sistema a sa mga tuntunin ng density Matrix na paglalarawan ng pure state na sinimulan natin na katibayan ket s
bra s kaya ito ang aming formula para sa reduced state ng sistema a ipagpalagay na ang compound system AB ay nagsimula sa
pure State s ngunit maaari rin nating gamitin ang formula nang mas pangkalahatan sa partikular ipagpalagay
na ang state ng ab ay ibinibigay ng ilang density Matrix rho na maaaring kumuha ng anyo ng ket s bra s para sa ilang Quantum State
Vector s ngunit hindi kinakailangan sumusunod ito mahalagang sa pamamagitan ng linearity na ang reduced state ng a ay
tinutukoy ng parehong formula tulad ng mayroon tayo para sa Pure State maliban na pinalitan natin ang anumang density Matrix rho na
nais natin bilang isang shorthand na notasyon medyo karaniwan na tukuyin natin ang reduced state na ito ng anumang pangalan na ginagamit natin para sa density
Matrix Row sa kasong ito ngunit naglalagay tayo ng subscript na nagpapahiwatig ng sistema na nakatuon tayo kaya ang rho na may
subscript na a ay nangangahulugang reduced state ng a kapag ang compound system ay nasa state na rho ang mga superscript ay minsan din ginagamit
sa halip ng mga subscript ito ay mahalagang personal na kagustuhan lamang at nangangahulugang parehong
bagay nakatuon tayo sa sistema a para sa kasimplihan ngunit maaari rin nating makuha ang reduced state ng sistema B
sa katulad na paraan ngunit kung saan ang formula ay inangkop sa natural na paraan lahat ng bagay ay simetrikal dito
mahalagang pinapalitan lamang natin ang mga papel ng A at B at sa partikular ang kabuuan ay sumasaklaw sa mga classical state ng a sa pagkakataong ito
kaysa sa b at sa formula sa screen ang tinatanggap nating ang classical State set ng a ay tinatawag na
Sigma lahat ng ito ay generalize sa medyo simpleng paraan sa tatlo o higit pang mga sistema halimbawa kung mayroon tayong tatlong
sistema a b at c na sama-samang nasa state na inilalarawan ng density Matrix rho kung gayon maaari nating makuha ang
reduced state ng pares a kasama ng b ng formula na ipinapakita dito gayundin ang state ng ikatlong sistema nang mag-isa
na siyang pangalawang formula at maaari kang gumawa ng iba pang mga kombinasyon at generalize ito sa anumang bilang ng mga sistema ang mga kabuuan ay palaging kinukuha sa
mga classical State set ng mga sistema na binalewala at ang pattern ay palaging parehong may density
Matrix na sinimulan natin na sinandwich sa pagitan ng tensor product ng identity Matrix at mga bra at ket na tumutugma sa mga standard basis
state upang tapusin ang aralin ay sasabihin ko ng kaunti pa tungkol sa mga kahulugang katatapos nating talakayin ang operasyon sa density
matrices na naglalarawan ng mga reduce State ay may pangalan at ito ay tinatawag na partial trace para sa dalawang sistema A at B ang
partial Trace sa B at ang partial Trace sa a ay gaya ng tinukoy dito sa screen ang mga ito ay eksakto parehong
mga formula na nakita natin kaaalis pa lamang at ngayon ay iniisip na lamang natin ang mga ito bilang mga function ng rho at binibigyan sila ng
mga pangalan ang mga pangalan ay mukhang trace maliban na mayroong subscript na nagsasabi sa atin kung aling sistema ang tinatanggal
o sa madaling salita kung aling sistema ang isa na ang classical State set ay binibilang natin at sinasandwich sa pagitan ng isang bra at isang
ket kapag kinukuha natin ang partial trace ng aming B halimbawa na inilalarawan ng unang Formula minsan ay sinasabi natin na
ang b ay traced out at gayundin para sa a sa intuitive na pagsasalita ang pag-trace out ng isang
sistema ay nangangahulugang itinapon natin ito o binalewala lamang ito iyon ay isang paraan upang tukuyin ang partial
trace at ang isa pang katumbas na paraan ay ang sabihing ang mga mapping na ito ay natatanging linear na mga mapping na nagsasagawa ng
mga formula na ipinapakita dito sa kanan partikular kung mayroon tayong tensor product ng dalawang matrix M at N halimbawa
at gumaganap tayo ng partial Trace sa unang sistema kung gayon ang nakukuha natin ay ang trace ng unang Matrix M beses
ng pangalawang Matrix at ang kondisyon ay simetrikal kapag nag-trace tayo sa pangalawang sistema hindi ang bawat Matrix na
kukuha tayo ng partial trace nito ay isang tensor product tulad nito ngunit ang bawat Matrix ay maaaring ipahayag bilang isang linear combination ng
mga tensor product at maaari nating matukoy ang partial Trace mula sa mga kondisyong ito kasama ang katotohanan na ang mga ito ay linear
na mga function at ito ang dahilan kung bakit ito ay tinatawag na partial trace ang katumbas na kahulugang ito ay maaaring
medyo kapaki-pakinabang dahil madalas nating magagamit ito kaysa sa orihinal na formula narito ang isang halimbawa na
nagpapakita nito ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong isang pares ng mga cubit a na nasa state na ang density Matrix ay ipinapakita dito sa
screen ito ay nangyayaring isang halimbawa ng isang correlated na state kung saan ang a ay nasa zero State o sa one state bawat isa
ay may probabilidad 1/2 kaya maaari nating isipin ang a bilang classical kung ang a ay nasa zero State kung gayon
gayundin ang B at kung ang a ay nasa one state kung gayon ang B ay nasa plus state kung gusto nating malaman kung ano ang reduced state ng a ay
kina-trace out natin ang B at kung gagamitin natin ang pangalawang formula mula sa katumbas na kahulugan kasama ang linearity kung gayon
medyo madali nating makalkula ito sa partikular ang trace ng ket 0 bra 0 ay isa gayundin ang trace ng ket plus bra
plus kaya nawawala ang mga tensor factor na iyon at naiwan tayo sa completely mixed state sa katulad na linya maaari tayong kalkulahin
ang reduce state ng B sa pamamagitan ng pag-trace out ng a sa pagkakataong ito ito ang unang tensor factor na sinasagawa natin ang trace kaya
gumagamit tayo ng unang Formula mula sa katumbas na kahulugan at naiwan tayo sa 1/2 beses ket 0 bra 0 plus 1/2 beses ket
plus bra Plus o sa madaling salita ang parehong density Matrix na lumitaw ng ilang beses na dati makukuha mo ang eksakto parehong
mga resulta kung gagamitin mo ang mga formula mula sa unang kahulugan ngunit ito ay isang mas madaling paraan upang gawin ito lahat ng ito ay generalize sa tatlo o higit pang
sistema ngunit para sa video na ito ay titigil na ako dito at iiiwan ito para sa iyo na isaalang-alang sa iyong sarili at iyon na ang aralin na ito na
nagpapakilala ng mga density matrix at naglarawan ng mga pangunahing kaalaman ng kung paano sila gumagana tinalakay rin natin ang block sphere
gayundin ang iba't ibang uri ng mga correlations at ang konsepto ng reduced state ng isang sistema umaasa akong sasama ka sa
susunod na aralin na tungkol sa mga channel na mga linear mapping mula sa mga density matrix patungo sa mga density matrix na
naglalarawan ng mga operasyon sa mga sistema paalam hanggang sa
muli tayo magkita